the sovereign the Ravagers
they all want us dead that's a really
bad sign the Guardians must be destroyed
hit me with your best shot
oh wow no and almost hit me
hey youtubers new guardians footage
let's break it down hyping up a Ravagers
fight so I'll explain that but James
Gunn also revealed a whole bunch of new
information so I have a special video
that I cut down from him if you're new
to the channel I do Marvel and DC videos
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything and leave all your requests
in the comments below so what they're
basically hyping up is that the Ravagers
will be one of the big antagonists of
the film in addition to the sovereign
which is basically a stand-in for the
group in the comics that are responsible
for creating Adam warlock so there's
your big Adam warlock Easter Egg that's
why they're all colored gold to look
like Adam warlock and if you didn't spot
him here there's a giant Easter egg they
haven't revealed that he's part of the
movie now this is an Adam warlock but
this is Ben Browder from far escape
James Gunn is just like a huge Farscape
fan so he tried to fit him into the
movie so we don't know who he's playing
what his role is he looks like some sort
of military man but put all your
conspiracy theories in the comments
below it's just I don't think he's
supposed to be Adam warlock but James
got did this big Q&A that I cut down
where he talks about the collector the
characters that are gonna be in the
future films the spin-off movie that
he's talking about for rocket and Groot
so I'm gonna play that video it's a
couple minutes long pay attention
because he reveals some really cool
stuff but I'll recap that at the end of
this um we're gonna get a Groot spin-off
movie who knows I mean you know I think
it'd be a lot of fun to do different
spin-offs from guardians and we'll see
who those are I have a lot of ideas
about what would be potentially true if
I stick around
is this Groot the same group from the
last film and does he have the same
memories and feelings no he is not the
same Groot
he does not have the same memories he
does not have the memories of a dull
crew it's been doing the voice of baby
Groot yes he is he is totally doing the
voice he's already done it
do I miss working with Benicio I do I
just talked to Benicio a couple weeks
ago he's a great actor a great guy the
collector wasn't right for the story of
guardians of galaxy vol 2 because
although it's incredibly enormous film
it's a it's a much smaller film in
certain ways with fewer amounts of
characters so he just didn't fit in but
I would love to work with Benicio and
the collector again guardians volume 2
is a much bigger movie in so many ways
but again in terms of the actual cast of
characters the amount of people in the
movie
it's a much smaller size in fact I had
that to cut some cameos from the movie
from friends of mine which was awful to
me and and and sucked and so that's
that's no fun and he surprised
characters and guardians of the galaxy
volume 2 yes there are quite a few
how many Easter eggs in the new film
there's quite a few quite a few there's
one we made yesterday or finalized
yesterday that's really truly pretty
funny the April Fool's joke of stallone
and rosen bombs rolls what do you think
I don't know I mean so an article came
out on April Fool's Day that said
Sylvester Stallone was playing Galactus
and Michael Rosenbaum was playing the
Silver Surfer
and the guardians of the galaxy another
April Fool's joke came out that said
that I got a sleeper in mind that said
that the MCU and the Star Wars universe
were we're joining and that I had
announced that and some big announcement
both of those things of course are
untrue I have not revealed who Sylvester
Stallone is playing in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 I have not revealed who
Michael Rosenbaum is playing in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 there are
other people who we haven't revealed so
it was just kind of I don't know I guess
was it funny
I don't know was a way to get a lot of
clicks I guess that worked can marvel
make an r-rated movie if they want
I mean we've we've discussed it before
we've talked about it so when will we
get Howard the Duck or that was a Tati's
only credit or a mid-credits scene and
end credits scene does not mean that we
are making a contract with the audience
that those characters will have a solo
film for us it was a fun thing
well how are the duck reappear within
the MCU probably does that mean there
will be a Howard the Duck movie who
knows it's not incredibly likely but you
never know there's a lot of movies left
a lot of characters left in the MCU and
there is as long as this world will last
which will hopefully be longer than some
are afraid it will last right now are
you excited about Captain Marvel yes I'm
very excited about Captain Marvel I
think brie Larson is terrific somebody
asked me what I like to work with the
Russo brothers and any other Marvel film
I of course am executive producer
infinity war so I've been working a lot
on that and making sure that the
Guardians stay true to themselves and
they speak correctly and speak like
themselves and and and make the choices
they would make in real life within
those their supporting roles within
those movies what was the craziest thing
you pitched a Marvel that they approved
without hesitation I think a lot of
things have been crazy obviously having
you know you know ego is such a big role
in guardians of the galaxy volume 2 was
a big thing I also think just pitching
when I first went in on guardians of the
galaxy and pitched the idea of so much
of the movie revolving around this Sony
Walkman and in fact when I gave the
folks at Marvel my very first treatment
of the story that I was going to to
write I put a picture at the top of the
first page which was a Sony Walkman so
it was incredibly important in the
emotional story and I think that was
always a crazy thing for them to agree
to now there used to me pitching crazy
things and accepting them and we see a
lot of really outlandish things in
guardians of the galaxy volume 2 that
we're almost used to when will we see
the full tracklist for awesome mix vol 2
well I know exactly when you're gonna
see it unless it slips out early and
it's it's not too long it's a couple
weeks and then you'll see the full
tracklist and know everything about it
and when you talk more about that then
so all really cool stuff but what he's
hyping up is that the collector isn't in
guardians to but he's been confirmed in
Atlanta while they're filming infinity
war so it's like okay he is very
definitely gonna be part of that because
as an elder of the universe in the
possessor of one of the Infinity stones
he has a very important role to play so
just not going to be happening in
guardians to the extraordinary strength
observe
one down
[Music]
five to go
the rocket and Groot spinoff sounds like
more of a thing now he was teasing that
idea earlier instead of doing a direct
Guardian sequel but he says he does have
an idea for the third guardians film so
if you thought that he wasn't gonna do
any more Guardians films that's probably
not gonna happen but based on all the
films they already have scheduled for
phase three it's pretty likely we won't
see that for a long time and then Howard
the Duck that was so fun I loved that he
was like oh yeah there's definitely
gonna be a lot more Howard the Duck in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so just
keep your eyes peeled but obviously he
explained that the rumor about Silver
Surfer Galactus completely untrue
most of you probably saw that and were
like yeah that is definitely 100% fake
especially because it's on April Fool's
but even if you saw it on any other day
you probably wouldn't believe it just
because Kevin Feige himself has said
that there have been no meaningful talks
with Fox about any kind of crossover
just because they're blowing it up with
Deadpool and all that rated R films but
I do like the idea that he said that
Marvel has talked about doing a rated R
film so we can all guess about what
that's going to be but that doesn't mean
that they're going to be making one
during phase four it just means that
they've talked about the idea so let me
know in the comments if they do rated
our character what do you want them to
do now keep in mind that Sony is talking
about doing a venom movie that's a
Spider Man character so they have the
rights to that Marvel does not so it'd
have to be some big bankable team like
you could do Thunderbolts as a rated at
our movie Marvel has the rights to that
they could also do Moon Knight if they
wanted to rated our Moon Knight would be
badass
so let me know in the comments what's
your pick rated our Marvel film but
what's gonna happen next is I'll post
new Rick and Morty new flash season 3
tomorrow agents of shield is back so
that video will probably post Wednesday
morning hail Hydra so while you wait for
that you can click here to learn about
the special Jarvis AI that Iron Man
built into Spider Man suit and
homecoming and you can click here for
brand new Rick and Morty thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys in the next video